I literally failed at everything that
wasn't directly going to serve my
purpose the only thing that you're
responsible for is your best like you
can't do better than your best big thing
that makes a good day versus not a good
day is exposure to cold the motivation
much a top 10 the believe nation what's
that believe nation it's Evan I believe
in you and this channel is designed to
be a part of your daily success routine
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
man who went from failing multiple
businesses to finally starting an Inc
500 successful company that helps
millions of people around the world
optimize their lives he's also a
podcaster and successful author he's a
Bri Marcus and here's my take on his top
ten rules to success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one weaponize belief we're all really
good at detecting each other's belief to
a certain degree and you know at word
businessmen so for us it's probably
gonna come in a pitch meeting right like
or an employee or something like you'll
have that person come to pitch you you
have that employee come and they are
just so sure not overcompensating
because that actually is a sign of
insecurity right but just so calmly sure
that they are the right person and they
have the right idea that you may not
even get through a quarter of their
pitch you're like I'm in like I'm in you
in like I believe you a hundred percent
because you know that and you can kind
of sense that they've reconciled all of
their own fears all their own
insecurities and that they truly believe
that they got the goods and I think
that's somebody weaponizing their belief
that somebody who has done the hard work
to really know themself know their
product know what's going on and they're
utilizing belief to convince you far you
know far more than you know the
documents and everything else where's
you can have somebody else with a great
idea who's really insecure and not
confident doesn't believe in himself and
you'll look at it like I just don't
think it's gonna work you know and the
same can be said for fighters right
because fighters that's a very intimate
belief detection game I mean they're
right there at the at the weigh-in
staring at each other and they're right
there across from the ring and I think
not enough is talked about about
actually believing if you're gonna win
because I think the other person can
detect that as well so Conor McGregor is
someone who believes in himself so much
that he comes in at 100% belief and if
his you know if his opponent is coming
in at 99
all of a sudden that 1% difference is
gonna be a mountain it was like wow he's
at a hundred like a hundred percent
bleep well I'm only at 99 percent well
what does he know maybe he's right you
know and so that becomes a weapon for
him and has allowed him to be you know
one of the greatest mixed martial
artists in the world and and you'll see
that kind of across the board so it's
really just using belief to affect
reality in a positive way rule number
two be authentic you're in a very
competitive space the Nutri
wellness supplement space how do you set
yourself apart and really attract the
right customers for your brand I think
it I think we can get in kind of
marketing speak and we can talk about a
brand and we can think about how cool
that brand looks we can think about the
other associations that we can draw from
it by but I think there's an
authenticity and a truth to the movement
behind that that I think everybody
really needs to focus on like we can do
all of the different techniques and the
tools and that'll that'll generally work
but how real is the message that you're
putting out how authentic how valuable
is the product that you have like if you
scratch the layer of your scratch off
ticket that's your company is it more of
the same more of the same more the same
every different layer of the onion that
you cut through all the way to the
nucleus if you're the entrepreneur
you're the nucleus of that onion you
know are you expressing yourself through
that brand as fully authentically
passionately as you possibly can the CEO
you mean yeah the CEO or the founder
whoever you know whoever's at the center
of that business are they expressing the
message yeah is it is it is it real all
the way through through to the bone and
I think that's something that a lot of
people kind of skip over let's create a
brand it'll have this idea it'll have
this design spec it'll have this market
but but what is the real estate mission
what's the mission what's the meat of it
what's the heart of it and get that
thing right and you'll just start
attracting people that's like that
creates gravity and then that creates
you know satellites that'll start
orbiting you and other people and all of
a sudden you'll be at the center of a
solar system because you've had a dense
gravity of truth at this part of
whatever you started rule number three
grow through failures I failed it
absolutely everything I tried and like
what what did you try they didn't work
out literally everything I mean I tried
gold mining I tried some variety of
different online retail from sex toys to
skincare to I tried oil and gas I tried
like oil and gas like trading sighs no I
was I can invest like investor relations
you know like trying to convince people
to go bet on some Wildcat oil well in
the middle of nowhere
never works you know and I'd get some
stock options like this one's gonna hit
never hit nothing but now looking back
I'm grateful because I literally failed
at everything that wasn't directly going
to serve my purpose and all of those
failures all the lessons gave me the
strength to be able to hold an
organization of this magnitude that I'm
holding now like the person that I was
then couldn't run on it like I couldn't
write the book that I wrote I couldn't
do the things that I'm doing I couldn't
have this conversation now because my
ego would get in the way and all kinds
of things I wasn't ready yet and so the
universe was like no not ready fail fail
fail and up but I was like man well I'm
just I'm 30 and I'm failed at everything
you know I scratched out a little money
here and there you know I was doing
alright doing better than some of my
peers when I would go buy bottles at the
club and party like I could buy a more
expensive bottle than they could so
everybody's like yeah I'll be your kill
and I'm like I'm not killing it I'm like
blowing it and that was that was tough
and then finally it just kind of lined
up with the the right timing and the
right idea and the right person leading
it meaning me and I was able to come to
fruition rule number four collapse year
also just attack fear wherever you see
it even when it's trivial even when it's
some kind of we were just before that
before we got on here we talked about
the fear of the number 13 trig a trick a
phobia like if you're afraid of 13 you
know what you need to do you put 13s all
over your house you know you need to
like sit in 13s you need to go to the
13th demand to be on the 13th floor of
every hotel in every airplane because
you got to get over that because that is
telling yourself that there's something
irrational that should control you and
if you believe there's something that's
irrational that should control you that
will apply universally so wherever you
find fear specifically that's out of
balance with actual danger like I'm not
saying touch a hot stove or put your
hand in a rattlesnake cage like there's
danger there that's not fear but 13 no
danger you know that's not real
so go collapse that if there's a fear of
crickets like I have or a fear of like
whatever it is collapse fear wherever
you see it and that specific collapse
will help with the universal collapse of
fear in general rule number five serve
other
looking to start my own business what
advice do you have for me to sack up and
go for my win focus on the people you're
gonna help with that businessman you
know focus on focus on everybody that's
gonna benefit from your product focus on
everybody that's gonna benefit from your
wealth that you get when the business is
successful like make this business about
service to others and that will give you
not only the motivation but that will
harness the right kind of energy and the
right people to help you like the more
that you can just focus on giving the
more that you'll receive you know the
law of reciprocity is one that runs deep
deep deep into the cosmos you know we
have an intern internal balancing scale
in our head and in our heart and most
people do as well and if you can really
just focus on what you're gonna give
then and just trust that ultimately you
keep giving you're gonna receive rule
number six find balance
you really can't specialize in only one
thing and really reach the potential of
that thing you have to support
everything else like you can go super
hard in one direction but your health is
gonna fall apart your relationships
gonna fall apart and ultimately that's
gonna start being weights gonna be
anchors it's gonna drag against your
progress and it's gonna be a headwind
for you in anything that you're doing
and it's the same with the body like you
can take great supplements but if your
nutrition is you and your workouts are
she and your sleep issue in your
mentality so what it's not gonna matter
so total human optimizations the idea to
raise everything at the same time and
really try to incremental improve and
it's not as flashy and sexy is this 30
day transformation expert in this one
area but it really works rule number
seven strengthen your mind big thing
that makes a good day versus not a good
day is exposure to cold really yeah like
wim HOF style you mean it's not it's not
a good day if you're not exposed to cold
it's not as good a day really it's not
as there's something about that not only
pushing yourself I do it early in the
morning and you can either do it in the
shower by start with a warm shower start
doing the wim HOF breathing which starts
to hyper oxygenate the body also has a
lot of hell
benefits and then turning that shower
nozzle cold and how long for about three
minutes is what you want to do all the
way cold and if you have a cold pool or
cold baths you can do that but it's
twofold one it's going to reduce your
chronic stress so norepinephrine goes up
adrenaline goes up and it drops your
cortisol so it drops the baseline of
stress that we all carry all the time
but the other thing is it's That moment
right before you turn that nozzle where
every party bees like yeah not today
yeah fear you're like I don't want to do
don't want to do that you turn it over
singing that's called exactly exactly
even though you know it's not going to
hurt you even though you know it's gonna
benefit you it's gonna develop cold
shock proteins it's gonna help your
immune system you know people exposed to
cold get 43% less respiratory infections
like it's oppositely of the wives tales
that we've heard like don't go out in
the cold you'll you'll get sick like
regular and mediated exposure to cold is
actually gonna help your immune system
so even with all the work then it's
gonna boost the immune system boost the
more you do it yeah so you believe when
we have the discipline to put ourselves
through controlled stress for a few
minutes it's going to give us extreme
benefits the rest of the day no doubt
because it's the same thing like when
we're thinking about whether we want to
work out or not right right we're
sitting around like yeah you know I
really should go out and take that run
or really go out and take that work out
we know we're gonna feel better when we
do it we know we're gonna be better but
what is that part of ourselves that's
gonna turn that little bit extra over to
the yes column you know it's something I
call mental override and I talk about it
in the book it's the ability to use your
mind to give you that little extra to
push you into yes manual override yeah
and it's the same thing that you would
same thing that you would use with you
need to start that project or if you're
screwing around on emails and need to
actually get to the meat of the problem
at work it's that same mental technique
that's gonna allow you to kill it but
you get to practice that in the morning
and you get to have that small win so
that the next time you're facing that
off
I really should start that big project I
really should work on this you just have
that same attitude like alright I'm
gonna do it yeah rule number eight just
do your best you just got to understand
the only thing that you're responsible
for is your best like you can't do
better than your bat
you just do your best and if you try to
obsess too much you're not doing your
best you're gonna be paralyzed right so
you have to get as much information as
you can make the most educated choice
make sure that you're not choosing based
on ego or emotion or you know greed or
these other forces that delude you and
prevent you from thinking clearly but if
you do your best and you fail like what
are you gonna do beat yourself up for
that like that doesn't make any sense if
you're doing your best if you're really
laying it out there there's nothing
nothing more you can do and and that's I
think that's really the key is just to
constantly rest and rely on that fact
that I'm just I'm doing my best and
there's nothing nothing more than that
rule number nine enjoy every moment when
is the last time that you cried tears of
joy do you remember oh man and that
wasn't too long ago that's that's a more
frequent occurrence for me actually and
as I've done you know a lot of work on
my life and it hasn't been the external
stuff that ever makes me cry tears of
joy it's not a big on it success it's
not something external that happens it's
really just sitting in a moment it can
be with a lover that I'm sharing a night
with and I'll just start crying and just
the experience of enjoying that simple
moment or laughing with friends or I
mean it's actually a rather frequent
occurrence and that's one of the best
indicators for me that the path that I'm
on is yielding the kind of fruit that
I'm really looking for and looking to
forage because I catch myself doing that
all the time I actually today I had a
little informal mentorship with one of
my employees and just as I saw that
breakthrough moment I saw that moment
where you know I was talking about her
working not on her business not on her
career and on it but on her heart and
how that and she was like yeah it's a
big project and I go yeah it is a big
project and I saw that light come up and
just the tears will come in that moment
for me too it's just like yeah you know
like I'm I'm doing what I'm supposed to
be doing and then just the gratitude for
being able to do what I'm supposed to be
doing it'll just it'll calm and real
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is get in the state
of love I think it's a fallacy it's a
mistake anytime you look external
you think oh man if I only had that
person's life if I was only in there
because everybody has their own relative
experience of what they're going through
and the harder you push the more you
drive yourself from whatever starting
point you had however hard you push the
resistance is gonna push back and
resistance is gonna find the cracks in
the foundation you know it's that weight
and different things that are out of
alignment will start to be painful like
putting pressure on a fracture on a bone
you know the more you push on that bone
the more that nerve endings gonna shoot
up a signal and say hey you better fix
this or you're gonna increase in pain so
you have the choice then you either numb
it out distract yourself you know have
some drinks do whatever else you want to
do or you get to the root of the problem
which is somewhere in the psyche can you
ever just I'm happy and I figured out
how to be happy and I'm good to go now
I want to believe that's yes but I
really do and I think I think you can
get closer like I think the the lighter
pressure reveals the bigger cracks the
heavier pressure reveals some of the
deeper smaller cracks and then you keep
working your way down and I believe that
there is a solid foundation under there
and that solid foundation is typically
love and if you can get all the way back
to love because there's no cracks in
love it can't crack the can't break it
can't be divided and if you can get back
to that state of love and gratitude and
forgiveness for yourself appreciation
for the world if you can get there then
you can be happy truly through and
through but it's not going to be any of
the external that you accomplish that
does that it's going to be the external
putting pressure on you internally
that's going to allow you to reach that
next level right
now I've got a really special bonus clip
of Marcus talking about how to train
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that is that for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go
question number one what failure do you
need to grow through right now number
two how can you strengthen your mind to
get there
and number three how can you serve
others more to accomplish your goals
there's no exactly right way to take the
miracle drug call training now I call it
a miracle drug because it improves
virtually every single system in the
human body it'll help your sleep it'll
help mood issues like depression and
anxiety it'll help you look better lose
weight it'll help your sexual
performance it literally helps all
aspects of the human body helps you live
hunger but the funny thing is is that
most of us don't take the minimum
effective dose we don't take the
recommended daily allowance and partly
that's because we don't know what we're
doing we don't know how to do it and
some of it is just pure willpower that
idea of mental override where you just
got a step foot start sweating and get
moving
and also perhaps our motivations are
wrong maybe the only reason we're coming
in to exercise or the traine is to look
really strong and get tough and that was
the explosion of these Globo gym machine
weights where you're just like focusing
on your pack so your biceps are working
one muscle at a time for aesthetics well
you do that you're gonna build
imbalances and also it's not adequate
motivation you know really you got to
get in here because you love how the
animal feels when the animal starts to
move raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that that people
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to mean
if you like this video check out the one
I did on tom bill you and his top ten
rules to success I think you'll enjoy
the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so my entire youth I feared pain I
moved away from pain if something was
emotionally or physically difficult I
avoided it